Johnny ever heard of a woman named
Ingrid Ingrid Bergman yeah yeah she went
West Charles Cooper first want to
request this that on the red band
Charles Cooper here we go
this is all for you only you're a lot of
oil is Aubrey Plaza's in this all right
the couple that you missed together stay
together
prayer handles a perfect day for a
perfect wedding
hashtag perfect happy to be hearing this
day with all my favorite team - sighs
left in this real hashtag no - birthday
press perfect life yeah angry
congratulations
[Music]
are you insane
[Applause]
anything else I mean Laurel
[Music]
[Applause]
this is Nikki oh how long are you here
for what I think I know what this is
about it but I would like to go back to
I'm gonna go to IMDB really quick
Ingrid a mentally disturbed young
because obsessed with Taylor Sloane
Olsen a social medias okay yes so she's
obsessed with a social media so I picked
up on that
but when Inger decides to drop
everything and move west of a friend
Taylor her behavior turns unsettling and
increasingly dangerous ooh I love it
I've always wanted something like this
to happen to me the biopic you wish you
had I want someone from like Alaska to
be on set with me and just see think I
have the perfect life and then like
travel over here come knock at my door
they want to be my friend and I'm like
I'm sorry I'm calling the cops but this
is what I really want I want a drama you
know I want the drum cops come and
everything get a restraining order
they're stalking me at parties I go up
to me to leave my family alone let me go
[ __ ] like that I took out the screaming
it's got a restraining order tase you
yeah but then they get like evidence on
me you know the fucked-up things I would
really do oh man only do you expose it
unless I agreed to just all I really
wanted to do was play baseball I mean
whole time come on began kidnap your
Katzman stuff so you let them live over
that's one of the things going to kill
more like I don't like this joke game
one and then they're going to make like
a silicone mask of you know here's good
yeah like and then you know that would
be a cool shot to just like someone
walking directly towards Cameron and
Greg masks that looks really real taking
a selfie or something yeah like it we're
doing it let's make this happen for your
life I loved the opening
for this trailer I thought like
capturing and I like her like when she's
looking at the phone reading the
comments I have the whole style of it
was done it just is like yeah I know I
kind of know the feeling not to like
this degree but you know the feeling and
when you're just like I can't get the
[ __ ] off social media for some reason
and you're my just wrapped up in all
this [ __ ] and everyone is having a prat
day like here at Darby I love that you
don't hang on the phones is brightly lit
yeah I thought that was a really cool
trailer I really I really enjoyed that
the obsession with with you know
perception oh yeah how she pursued this
perceives her life on social media must
she like wants that to be her reality
but it's just not make sure my to be
good way oh man look at ever straighter
than fake oh man that was that was
insane because yeah they're like posting
the whole time while you're at live with
during your wedding you know you just
can't get off social media hey I'm yeah
I'm I can't imagine something like this
has happened before
FOMO is a real thing man like it's a
real epidemic that makes people do weird
[ __ ] this looks like a batshit crazy
movie though I love it I'd say I'm glad
you read the plot because this trailer I
had no idea this is one of those trailer
I like a trailer like this in a sense
it's like a beaver dream it's just a
bunch of crazy images yeah but that's
what I that's why I love the whole
trailer because you say fever dream and
this is a girl who's obsessed with these
illusions you know I don't know what
scale this movie is going to go out on
but this seems like one of those kind of
when you read the synopsis it seemed
like one of those you know one of the
edgy comedies but that's not just an
edgy cut like it seems like it might not
be afraid to get into some actually
morally dubious area oh no yeah I mean I
guess no say comedy in there like it's
if anything it's a really dark comedy
yeah all right that's not I don't know
like there's a there's a certain
edge to it and and I guess yeah there's
definitely a political commentary on to
that there's at least a lot of like
awkward humor in here yeah whole thing
at and where's your just staring at the
guy that you take the picture yeah this
is I had no idea this was a thing until
just now so I like I like stories of
people who get obsessed or stalkers I
love those kind of stories and I love it
when that's on the perspective of them
okay like talented mr. Ripley I really
like one-hour photo I like it when that
this is from the perspective of Aubrey
Plaza that makes her much more
fascinating kind of film to me Aubrey
Plaza doing a much darker role it's
about time you know she says she does a
lot of these weird comedies then and now
should this is like alright is a cool
role I can see Aubrey Plaza leading you
know they're not just weird quirky girl
or randomly now you're super sexually
hot girl you know who made this oh dude
I know exactly who made this Matt Spicer
you heard Matt Spicer right yeah he's
like my house guy he's sort of Melissa
McCarthy makes good but nothing we've
heard of Alva dude it's co-written by
madness Michael Ian and David Bronson
Smith who was on the miscellaneous crew
of enlightened I don't care man all I
care about it this movie looks really
entertaining and this looks like
something I can semi relate to and I
fantasize about happening to me yet I've
said it for years on this channel and no
one have come to stalk me I'm sorry no
one I can try to find somebody I don't
mean like Twitter messages or like I'm
talking like where'd you get this photo
look at RL I can take an ad out on
Craigslist or something I want to be on
like having dinner with my family at
Denny's and then suddenly they have
there they take a photo with black and
white you know they're always a black
and white photo
deranged people just don't like comment
subscribe to the real rejects hey
hey Prince Jerry on Clarence two
grandchildren sees the managing social
media of your lives on the real rejects
and Blum house if you want good movie
article knowledge I don't know how to
promote you I'm sorry so guys go there